-Our first guest tonight
is an Oscar-nominated actor
you know from "Boardwalk Empire"
and films
like "Nocturnal Animals"
and "Revolutionary Road."
He stars in
"Nine Perfect Strangers,"
which is streaming on Hulu
with new episodes
premiering Wednesdays.
Let's take a look.
-God. You got some balls,
shaming me about some wine
and a couple of KIT KATs.
All the while, you're dosing us
with psychedelics?
I mean, look, I'm no angel.
You know, I had a few
cocaine nights in the '90s,
but who didn't?
-I didn't!
-I believe that.
-You know, you --
You could go to jail for this.
-I could, but I'm not going to,
because you're going
to be thanking me.
-Please welcome back to the show
our friend Michael Shannon.
[ Applause ]
-Hey, everybody.
Thanks, bud.
-Thanks for being here, buddy.
Always a pleasure.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Hey.
♪♪
-It's so lovely to have you
back in the studio.
-Oh, it's nice to be here.
It's been a hot minute.
-It has been a hot minute
and a lot of --
It's been a hot mess in between
the two hot minutes.
-Yes, a hot messy minute.
-[ Chuckles ]
So, you play
one of nine perfect strangers
who go to
a-a wellness retreat...
-Yes, sir.
-...run by Nicole Kidman.
You -- I mean,
you're a Brooklyn guy...
-Uh-huh.
-...not an L.A. guy.
I feel like wellness
is a real L.A. thing,
but I guess Brooklyn
a little bit, too.
Have you ever bought into
the wellness craze?
-Well, yeah, there's a --
There's a yoga place
down the block from my house,
and I-I tried it out.
-How'd it go?
-Uh...
Yeah, I don't have
the inherent, intrinsic balance,
I think, to pull it off.
-Yeah.
-I got frustrated.
They kept asking us
to do things on one foot
or, you know, put your foot
in your knee or do all these --
And I just would always kind of
wobble and eventually fall over.
So I wound up injuring myself
more than anything. So --
-I also -- Please do not
take this the wrong way,
but I feel like I know you,
I know you to be
a very sweet person.
But I feel like people
that know you from your work,
if they were, like,
in a yoga studio and saw you,
they would not --
It would be, like, not,
like, a good,
very peaceful thing.
-You know, honestly,
I-I don't think I intimidated
any of these people.
I think they --
I think they felt sorry for me.
[ Laughter ]
They thought, "You really
don't belong here."
But, you know, it's --
It's an amazing -- It's an
amazing kind of strength,
the people that can actually
do this stuff.
It's not, you know, they're not
like bodybuilder strength,
but they -- They're really
strong, and I can't do it.
-Yeah, they're sneaky strong.
I think that, like,
if I could go back in time
and had started anything,
it would not be a sport.
It would've been, like,
as a young man, do yoga.
I feel like I'd be a lot --
I'd be in a lot better shape.
-Yeah, yoga, pilates.
-Yeah.
-Pilates.
-We both -- We both
sort of came up in Chicago.
I feel like that would have been
even more frowned upon
amongst the Chicagoans.
-Well, you know, it's funny, I
was just at this little theater.
I'm with the Red Orchid
in Chicago on Wells Street,
and right next door
to our theater,
they opened a pilates studio.
-Yeah, see? It's changing.
But I do think
like 20, 25 years ago,
it was maybe a little bit harder
to find pilates in Chicago.
-It was. Yeah, it was more --
That whole neighborhood
has just really changed.
There used to be like a Ripley's
Believe It or Not over there,
like, a head shop, and stuff.
It was kind of like
the Haight-Ashbury of Chicago,
and now it's just
totally squared up.
-It's really hard to keep a
Ripley's Believe It or Not open
these days.
-I know,
and now when we need them
more than ever.
-Yeah, we really --
[ Laughter ]
-Can you believe it?
-Yeah.
"Go down to the Ripley's."
"I tried to. It's a pilates."
-[ Laughs ]
-You got to spend time
in Australia shooting this.
-I did.
-Did you enjoy that?
-It's beautiful. You know,
I had been there 20 years ago
to make "Kangaroo Jack."
But that was --
[ Laughter ]
-This is where you wish --
Yeah, I mean, my God.
[ Applause ]
I mean, I -- I've gotten used
to not having an audience.
But if there was ever a time
I wish we had one --
-Uh --
[ Laughter ]
No, I just -- I've actually --
Never mind.
So, but that was a very --
That was in the outback.
And this was on the beach,
Byron Bay, which is
just one of the most exquisite
beaches in the world,
well regarded for surfing.
-Yeah.
-Everyone there is constantly
talking about surfing.
"Are you surfing today?
Are you surfing later?
Are you surfing tomorrow?
Is it the right day
to go surfing?"
And I-I-I just was --
felt a little out of my element,
'cause I don't surf at all.
-Any -- Was -- Did you have
any pull to try that?
-I tried
the paddleboarding one day.
-Right, which is not surfing.
-No. It seems like an easier
version of surfing.
-Yes.
-But -- But very much like yoga,
I don't think
I had what it takes.
-Yeah, that's true. If you
couldn't do "stand on one foot,"
I feel like you've
eliminated yourself.
-[ Laughing ] I can't
stand on a paddleboard.
So, but I --
I-I took long walks
on the beach,
long, romantic
walks on the beach.
By myself.
[ Laughter ]
-Can they be romantic
if you're by yourself?
-Well, depends on how you feel
about yourself, I guess.
Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Did you see --
I mean, I'm wondering,
you must be a celebrity
to some degree
amongst even the wildlife,
based on "Kangaroo Jack."
But did you see --
Did you see any --
I mean, like, do people
actually see koalas
when you go to Australia?
-Yes.
It's very rare.
-It is.
-The koalas are having
a tough go of it right now.
-Yes.
-And --
But we were -- As --
If you watch the show,
you'll see a kind of
a natural, outdoorsy place.
And -- And we actually saw two
of them throughout the shoot,
and, which everybody on the crew
told us how unbelievably lucky
we were to be seeing these.
And they're -- They're --
They're amazing.
They really are, as much
as you've seen pictures of them
or, you know, cartoon,
animes, whatever,
to actually see one in the flesh
is pretty remarkable, yeah.
-That's really cool.
I feel like that would --
That ticks the box
of the Australian experience.
-Yeah.
-You also have --
Your daughter
went to school there,
because you went
for the whole year, right?
-Well, I went for five months,
and my family was able to
join me for about half of that.
And my little daughter Marion
was able to go to school,
because where there --
where we were,
there weren't any cases,
and it was pretty safe.
So once you did your quarantine,
you could kind of go about
a regular life, you know?
So, yeah, we got her
into this Catholic school,
just 'cause it was kind of
the easiest one to get her into.
And, yeah, we're not
devout people,
a devout family ourselves,
but she actually had
a little exposure to that.
-How'd she take to it?
Did she dig it?
-She really did, because
it wasn't the kind of stern,
you know, nuns with rulers
kind of --
Like, her teacher was named,
like, Miss Honeybell.
-Oh, my.
-And she's a beautiful blonde.
She was just always smiling.
And they had very uplifting --
like, they had a little thing
they'd say at lunch
before they ate their lunch.
It was, "Yum, Yum, munch, munch,
thank you, Jesus,
for our lunch."
-Same.
-And it was like, "Yay!"
You know, it was more like --
-Yeah, it kind of, like,
makes you think,
"Why did they ever
go with nuns?"
-Yeah, right? It was --
You know,
if I could turn back time --
-There's a lot of things
we would have done.
We'll be right back with more
from Michael Shannon.